hier c'était le premier ministre qui
avait annoncé que la france se
comptaient bien rattraper son retard en
matière de développement du système
internet qui pourraient être accessibles
par le minitel actuellement uniquement
utilisé sur le territoire national une
passerelle entre les deux systèmes est
d'ailleurs possible
la société matra un prototype tout près
patricia charnelet la guerre le secret
était bien gardé
le nouveau minitel français vous
permettra l'année prochaine d'avoir
accès à internet le réseau mondial
d'informations avec ses partenaires
matra et alcatel france télécom met
actuellement au point ce nouveau joujou
vous pourrez vous en servir pour
téléphoner pour utiliser le minitel et
pour vous connecter à internet
cela va vous permettre un accès très
simple très conviviale à internet en
continuant à vous offrir l'accès au
montet et le deuxième élément c'est que
ce produit sera beaucoup moins cher
qu'un pc prg est envisagée entre 2 et
3000 francs soit moitié moins qu'un
micro ordinateurs autre avantage la
simplicité il suffira de toucher l'écran
pour naviguer sur le réseau informatique
mondial
inconvénient ce minitel internet
n'offrira ni le traitement de texte ni
la lecture des cd rom mais avec ce
nouveau produit la france entrent enfin
dans la guerre technologique mondiale
personne ne sait encore qui en sortira
vainqueur
ceux qui proposent internet sur
l'ordinateur ou sur l'écran de
télévision ou sur le minitel
les français auront au moins le choix du
terminal pour communiquer avec la
planète